[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'm standing
here with Jorge.
Jorge has been applying
machine learning
to diabetic
retinopathy detection.
Hi, Jorge.
Thanks for joining us.
DR. JORGE CUADROS: Hi.
Nice to be here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK,
let's start with what
is diabetic retinopathy?
DR. JORGE CUADROS: So
diabetic retinopathy
is the main cause of blindness
among working-age adults
in the world.
And the sad thing is
that it's 90% preventable
if patients would get regular
eye exams and timely treatment.
The problem is that people
don't get regular eye exams,
and so we've been going out and
getting images of the retina
in order to get a
diagnosis to see who is
at risk for vision impairment.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And how
do you apply machine
learning to the problem?
DR. JORGE CUADROS: So right now
an ophthalmologist or an eye
doctor optometrist has
to look at the image
and determine what the
level of retinal disease
is before a patient
can be referred,
if they need referral
for treatment.
So with AI you can get an
immediate grading of what's
going on in the retina.
So you don't have to wait
sometimes an hour or two hours
or two or three days or even
weeks to get a response.
You can act immediately
for people that need care.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And I imagine
this is a scalable thing
as well for areas
that don't have access
to the same medical help.
DR. JORGE CUADROS: Right.
So vision impairment is expected
to increase by three times
by the year 2050.
So there's just not
enough manpower.
There's not enough eye
doctors in the world
to be able to take
care of everyone.
So this is really
the only chance
to be able to get the people
who need care into treatment.
To be able to identify them
and make sure that they're
able to get treated.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I see.
DR. JORGE CUADROS: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's
next after this?
What else do you think that you
can apply machine learning to
for people?
DR. JORGE CUADROS: Yeah,
so that's really exciting.
It looks like AI can see a lot
of things in the retina that
humans can't.
So we're looking to apply it
to cardiovascular disease,
neurological disease, and
a host of other problems
that we're hoping that
the algorithm can find out
with just a simple
retinal image.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Jorge, thanks for
sharing your story.
And thank you for the
work that you're doing.
DR. JORGE CUADROS: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm Timothy
Jordan, and this is I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]